um when I say forest I mean and Samba or
trees and I want to talk about how in
psyche learn we in Samba trees so very
generic forests so cycle learn commonly
is uses of the supervised learning
problem oh my god where you have your
given x and y and you wonder in this
function that maps from x to y in this
talk I'm gonna have X B to D and samples
my own features and why is one T how
many of you have used the cyclone API
familiar with it okay it creates a it's
a very nice interface where you could
create a model you could call fit to
train your model you call predict to
predict and a lesser known thing you
could call score to get the score for
classification its accuracy and for
every question is are to score so that's
API so let's jump right into it what's a
tree all right decision tree is where
has at this entry is where your your
sample start off at the root node and
end up at the leaf node do wineries
zillions so on the on top if you're a
petal width is less than 0.8 goes the
left if if it's more equal to the right
and it's gonna another leaf and then use
that leaf for prediction so if it ends
up in the orange one it's it's it's
gonna be classified as the first cost
because that's the majority class in
that leaf now growing a tree well if you
add a node and you want to split this
node into its children you go to every
feature you sort that feature you find
the split point in such a way that
you're chose it minimizes impurity of
children that means as a parent you want
your children to be more pure than pure
than you are so this is the whole
growing process
so that's tree growing we have and it
grows until it reaches stopping criteria
the way you control is do these type of
parameters and our decision tree
regression classifier there's max M
example leaves there's a lot of them but
today I want to specific about forest
since we have an forest classifier and
regressor where you go many trees it's
controlled by a type of RAM in a call
and estimators like the fourth hundreds
of called hundred trees but if the trees
are exactly the same they can predict
exactly the same thing so averaging them
would not be and do you any good so you
want the great happy little trees where
you have bootstrap you
we shop sampling we're which means
you're gonna sample with replacement and
for classification for every split we
don't look at every feature you can look
at a subset features
this adds diversity in the forest which
gives which means it learns different
parts of you take it outside when you
average them it gives you a better
prediction so Brendan for is very cool
how do you implement it well I'm in
scikit-learn our key building is we
don't write NP R Python you have to be
slow so we write insight on how many you
are stipend writers yeah sounds cool I'm
gonna show you lots of sites on alright
our sights on releases to kill ok very
important for later forest building uses
job limb which is paralyzed with Joplin
what is job limb job is a it defines a
very simple API for paralyzing code
every anyone can use this to powerless
that goal so by the phone and uses
multiple processes in this case I want
to dominate the API you create a
parallel object in this case and job to
get for that means it uses four cores
I'm you have to delay your function
because you want to make it lazy and
then you iterate it to in this case it's
a squares a squared square root the
square and so it does this in parallel
so it's very simple to paralyze your
code how we do we take advantage of this
with tree building well for tree bearing
we define the same object but in this
case we preferred writing because our
site on coal releases to take Gil so
this we use multiple threads and since
the site owner uses the Gil we could
take advantage of multiple cores and so
we do the same idiom we delay the
function call and then this works so
this is what we do this is the actual
code of how we paralyze random forest
building okay so random forest is very
quick what school was what was
introduced in 0 21 which is histor
gradient boosting
which is our its own from the decision
of his'n grade including inspired by
like GPM so how many of you have used
like IBM kappas actually boos this is
another this is a former this is an
we've had our own implementations like
learn that's on par with HP M I gave a
very detailed talk about this three
weeks ago and encourage you to look at
it I'm gonna give a very quick elevator
pitch of how this works and this one
very quick boosting is a very
generic machine learning concept where
you really you want to create a function
you just function when I learn would be
a somewhat many other functions and you
train this it early you build a zero and
then you bear each one based on H zero
and so for and so on generator is
something called adaboost
that does this but today I want to talk
about gradient boosting when you think
of gradients you have loss functions so
for requestion we have V squared at
least absolute deviation check
classification we have cost MGP now once
you have a loss function which is a
scalar value we want to take the
gradient for example V squared
it's just difference and you square it
and you sum it all up it's a scalar
value but the gradient is a vector value
which means every sample has a
corresponding created with it which I'll
come to this point later what do you do
with these gradients well for grading
boosting you start with an initial
condition for these squared you just
take the mean so this is the most naive
prediction you could think of which is
the mean of your training set no it's
the target of a training set and then
the recursive condition adds different
functions to this prediction to make it
better this is not great in the sense
you're not updating weights you're
adding different functions on top of the
previous predictions a very different
distinction so I promise is the last
math equation I put on the side this is
the end of the day deliberately so in
this case for at least squared each of
em it's gonna be a leg of gradient and
you look closely at H of M of X the
we're solving now is having a subproblem
we want to find H of M such as a maximum
X to Y minus the previous prediction so
now we're stopping a subproblem italy so
how do you solve each of em how to get
each of them well since this is a do you
want to go too far in stock is trees and
how do you build the trees this is the
hissing gradient boosting his to form
histograms we need to have bins and the
first thing we do is pin our data so in
this visualization the x is the row
index and the y is the feature value and
so tube in our data set we take that
last in this case tendons
last simple set of data becomes 0 the
next ten percent becomes 1 and so for
and so on so we discretize our feature
space after that since each
has this correspond ingredient you could
put them in these bins so in this case
there's five bins and when place I can
sum them up and place them in their bin
so these are some of gradients we also
need Hessians because the algorithm
you've said it's kind of hand wavy but
after we've been in it this is where the
speed or outcome comes from so this is
for overview of the algorithm we've in
the data first as we saw before make an
initial prediction which is a constant
for B squared as a mean then we since we
have a prediction now we could calculate
the gradient by taking the difference
and then the tree building process we've
been we've been the data as shown like
this the cool thing about bending in the
data is that you have your split points
or not or set in stone they're on the
order of how many but how many bins you
have so it's yeah but your since your
future space is now smaller and the bins
are ordered so you don't have to sort
your data anyway once you've been the
data you have a sore thumb so this
greatly speeds up the algorithm for
hitting great increasing this is what
makes like you've been fast and what
makes history great increasing fast
that's the gist of it so how do you make
this how do we implement this and cycle
urn Queen use pure Python it'll be as I
said before it would be slow could be a
site on yes we do your site on but you
usually compile with OpenMP all right so
I'm gonna show you some site on code
which almost looks like Python code and
it's I'm gonna Steve show you what it
looked aches to make this parallel okay
so for bin data once once we bend it we
have to place the features in a bin
which is a binary search so if you stare
at this this is binary search but it's I
saw you the site on but if I didn't tell
you that it would look like pure Python
all right so this is site on is that
cool you know you could write just
Python and we'll just run in this case
if you look at the top its range so this
is in serial if I want to make this
parallel I just changed this range to a
P range and this is all it takes to make
this code take advantage or chords okay
so it's very simple in this manner so
I'm gonna show you a few more examples
when we spit when you find the best bit
I go to every feature you could use
independently so we could multi
processing on P range you could change
the range of P range and this will speed
up the finding the
features find the best bit point for
each feature so ok so that's so it's
cool Nexus and samples it could paralyze
over and samples and you do the same
thing this is all what this is doing is
writing to memory and we're doing in
parallel and boom it's faster so
compiling it if you write site on and
you want to make you if you take a bunch
of your course you could compile way
against OpenMP and it will make and just
mix much slightly changes and it will
make it go faster so it's awesome so the
boosting process if you go back and look
at API for the boosting process in
histone gradient boosting there is some
parameter control decreasing notice on
the top we need a naval history goosing
to import this it's our magic it because
our histone gradient boosting under
experimental so you have to import that
for to using great boosting next their
learning rate and and Max it erode
parameters based on boosting max it err
is how many trees you want to add to
your how many steps to boosting you want
to take that's how many trees you have
to if you want to grow the eggs there's
an environmental variable where you can
show how many cores you want to use so
you set this before you run your your
process so if I want to compare let's
say I want to do some benchmarking so I
one of the standard benchmarks we do is
the higgs-boson
dataset which is eight point eight
million records and twenty features it's
a binary classification problem if we
want to run this and use like.he p.m. or
SK learn there the time is about the
same it's around 30 seconds on 12 cores
the accuracy and our z score is about
the same as well so this is X expected
since we our implementation is based on
the buy cheaper mathematician but the
difference is that we write it insight
on and the implementation C++ there's so
many difference most of us don't have
twelve core machines so if you have four
cores it's gonna take more time but it's
gonna have the same accuracy so it's
it's comparable before course as well
so this is how we paralyze are the trees
and for random forests we have sites on
which releases the Gil and job Lib Dem
does multi-threading for histor gradient
boosting we cite on and OpenMP the big
difference for us is each tree could you
trained independently so you put in both
the course of the train insanity the
green and boosting or it strain it early
so it's so in this case to make it
faster you have to make
the growing of the tree faster and this
is what that's why we chose these
techniques now after we train these
models of these trees what can we do
with them after we train these trees
what coming through of them well we
could inspect them
in mono inspection we have permutation
points and partial dependence we also
have plot events so I want to show you
what permutation importance is without
any math it's gone I'm gonna show you
with an example okay let's say I want
the permutation importance of the first
feature of this data this is just
pretend data I made this up it's not
real it's a classification problem I'm
gonna fit my data and I'm gonna score it
and so this is classification it's gonna
be accuracy yeah accuracy afterwards I'm
gonna commute the first column though so
you see the first column was ordered
here I'm gonna computer I'm just gonna
shuffle it and then I'm gonna score it
again so and it's gonna give you no
numbers in this case 70% I'm gonna
commute it again yeah 73 I could keep on
doing this you know I keep on doing this
for as long as I want and I say I do or
three times and remember the original
score was 90% so the the definition of
permutation featurepoints
is going to be the difference between
these so in this case I took the
difference and you get something like at
the bottom the insight about this is if
a feature matters if you permute the
score if you commute the column it would
drop the has a score drastically because
it matters but if it doesn't matter
commuting the future will get would not
drop the score at all because it doesn't
matter so that's the basic intuition
around permutation importance so I did
this is quite manual here but as I could
learn we have permutation points which
would do this order do this for you so
in this case you shouldn't do it three
times but I did three times in exam so I
said repeats equal to three but you
can't do it you should do a lot more
times and what it returns to you is a
dictionary where the keys are the
importances which is the raw berries
that you saw before is the wrong
computer infusing importances and then
it is for ease of use we include the
stand evasion and the mean of the
these samples so let's look at this
let's look at future importance for a
real data set Rio isn't the Titanic this
is that um we have a fetch open ml which
allows you to access lots of data sets
on the open ml the server and in this
case IMAX a satanic this is new and 0
for 22 I could use as friend equal to
true which would return a data frame
okay
and afterwards I'm gonna add a random
category event number into the data
frame alright so these things are just
noise they do not matter at all okay
family add things into it how many of
you have used pandas and secular
together okay cool I'm gonna show you
something awesome how many of you have
used comm transformer column transformer
okay I'm gonna show you column
transformer I always I always like to
plug this whenever I can so I'm gonna
plug it now I'm gonna look at only like
a several columns though there's good
this data set has category goals and
numerix alright so I'm gonna go guys
I subset of them and I'm since we're
great diet science is you know we're
gonna train test fit them and this is
the column transformer alright so I'm
gonna create a pipeline just for the
categories so this gets categories
that's missing values so I'm gonna eat
it with the word missing and then I go
one hindquarter so this is this only
makes sense for categorical features and
you're not you're not going to do this
for numerical features and I'm gonna
have something very simple for the
numerix I'm just gonna I'm cute the mean
okay so what the comp transformer is it
allows you to create this single
transformer where like where you could
specify the categorical columns and know
it will pipe in that it passed the data
in these in these columns by name into
the category pipelines so only so this
specifies that the category pipeline
runs on the categorical features and
same thing for the numeric ones if you
could see it so this way after you have
this transformer you could place this
into another pipeline and then and then
pass it into event force classifier
because this is do you want a better
forest right so and then you call fit
and the cool thing about this is X chain
is a data frame it's going to pass
through the Khan transform and in the
transform its gonna run different
transformations based on the column name
and then it's gonna fit is gonna train
your model okay so that's it like a
slight detour and Collin transformer
it's awesome use it I'm gonna advertise
it it's been around for like two years
or something use it awesome okay so the
accuracy of this model is why I tend to
miss out on training which sure but the
test set is eighty-one percent so how
many of you have used feature points
from a tree before so this all right so
this is the feature points of this tree
all right you can see that the random
number is the most important feature
okay so that doesn't make sense much
right it turns out that the Van Voorhis
is heavily biased toward high carnality
features because it has many different
places like if since the venom has so
many places to split it's gonna choose
it more often than not because it has
high carnality
so what permutation points gives you is
the way to get feature importance I
think so you can run fermentation points
on the test set and it will give you a
way to and then you can see that the
numbers and the branded category it does
not matter in this case so it gives you
this power and which is very nice but
before you go around and just like who
I'm gonna use permutation points
everywhere I'm gonna give you some
warnings I'm gonna show you with another
day that said so this is the breast
cancer data set where the its
classification cancer renal cancer
I'm gonna train test fit this I'm gonna
train a random forest classifier because
do you wanna build a forest it's gonna
have 97% accuracy and I'm gonna run
permutation points on this so what
happens here well nothing it's important
all right so like the most important
thing is like this 0.008 right but
what's going on like what's going on
well it turns out most of the features
are correlated so if you have correlated
features and you shuffle a feature
that's correlated the formation still
there right
so the the squirt doesn't drop because
the features to it is in the dataset so
that so which means that you don't you
don't get if you don't get the proper
permutation points from this model from
the fermentation points so what do you
do about the situation is you see that's
big yellow block they're all just
correlated and there's a tiny little
blocks in the bottom well you just
select one of the features in the block
all right so it's it's very simple
concept but it's very important when you
use permutation importance so I'm gonna
select these features I'm gonna train it
I ran in class Safari I'm gonna do the
trains have split like yeah so I'm gonna
train on one it's gonna be 97 percent
same exact accuracy as before I'm gonna
do the permutation points again and you
can see that now stuff makes sense like
you know the mean radius and mean
concavity and the mean text like these
are important so this is one way to
inspect how your models behave with your
features so it's it's more inspection so
that's permutation points I want to talk
about partial dependence
I won't explain this without math again
this used to be math here but there's no
math anymore so because they so I'm
gonna have this data set it's regression
this time it's a toy there is that now
I'm gonna fit this model and you notice
that I don't want to find the partial
dependence on the first column first
column again the first feature so what I
do is you notice that the first feature
is its ordered just for make it easier
I'm gonna set the first column to all
zeros and I'm going to predict this
prediction is gonna give me five numbers
because it's five columns and we take
the mean let's say it's zero point one
all right I'm gonna do it again for the
one and from the first column and I'm
gonna predict again so I'm keeping
everything else constant and changing
just the first columns you have one and
two a constant am I gonna keep I could
keep on doing this I could do it for one
two three I just keep on doing it I can
make a plots okay so this plot on the
plot turns out to be something on the
left
so as this feature increases the the
prediction increases this means it has
an influence on your model it makes it
it makes it go up so this is this is the
partial dependence
if it was flat that means it has no
influence over the prediction tomorrow
okay so this is the essence of partial
dependence so let's run it to or the the
candidates that we had before we have
histogram gradient boosting let's try
and remember we have to do the
experiment so import enable history and
Chris thing I'm gonna fit I'm going to
score it it's gonna be 97% so I'm gonna
show AIDS up the plot pressure depends
API it's in its new it's just plotting a
pi is near and 0.22 I'm gonna this
filter it its plot part independence
needs the estimator the data you want to
train on and in this case I want to pass
it and comms equal to because I went to
columns it's gonna why because I'm gonna
pass features equal to these things
these are the top four features from
permutation points not by coincidence
and so these I want to plot these four
parts parentage these parts of
defendants plots so once I do that I'm
gonna create this plot two columns it's
gonna give you all this stuff and as you
see that for all these features as the
mean radius the mean concavity the mean
texture grows gets higher this feature
is go lower but let's say I let's yeah
again so yeah so I think as it increases
the probability of the cancer decreases
as these things increase now let's look
for comparison let's look at what it
looks like for the top two are the the
top the top two of the most important
according the permutation points the
next two are not important according
this warrant a permutation points the
bottom two so let's see what happens for
that case so the first two is what we
saw before the bottom two is what was
not important so increasing the mean
smoothness or the texture error would or
more flat compared to the top two so
it's kind of wait expects
if you look closely and squint you
notice that the plot partial dependence
returns this this is object the cool
thing about this API is that well
potting partial dependence is
kind of computation expensive yeah yeah
it's a lot of work so that this object
stores these things inside is in the
right object that means if you want if
you plot this thing like it's ugly I
want to make the line thicker all right
so I can set the line width equal to 4
and I set the keyword of line with you
go to 4 and as a dictionary
just forget goes who uses map problem
who loves map fat low okay I'll tell
them that I think so just set the line
languishes a property that you could set
on lines and it will make the line
thicker on all of them so what this did
was well the pressure dependence would
not be calculated it was it's already
stored in the object and I'm just gonna
set the line width on the when I plot it
I could pile again without computing
anything there's more to this object
remember there's four lines here so it's
stores stores the artists which is in a
grid and you could do ever you want to
come you can set the line width to ten
the line style to dashes set colors your
red I'd say hello world on the axis on
the bottom and ya know something like
this so you go you could kind of go nuts
yeah because and you could go nuts
because it it doesn't compute anything
it just sets change the style of your
plots
so that's awesome
so partial attendance we're going
through a lot today okay like really
quickly but we have sites on reuse site
line and drop live for Van Voorhis sites
on an open mp4 paralyzation inspection
we have permutation points and plot
parties dependence so these these
Monte's inspection tools are model and
Gnostic they don't have to be far as
this for this to work all the things
talk to stuff I have for my inspection
they could do you could do it for any
Maori once you could do for dinner let's
just aggression and regression and
everything all right so don't have to be
trees and I do want to show this demo
that's why I had this home since his'n
gradient boosting is like is the newest
estimator we have and cycle earn and
with Nick spent six months on it and I
want to showcase and it sparked
joy that it's worked so well I'm gonna
share this joy with you by showing you a
demo all right
end of the day demo I hope it works this
is ssh into a 12 core machine alright
okay you read that now okay alright so
i'm remember i have the export in this
case this core this computer has 12 cool
physical cores and 24 threads
open them p it's not good at hand on
multi-threading I mean not not good at
handing hyper threading alright so I'm
gonna set open ohmmm P number 8 to 12 so
which makes it so that uses 12 physical
cores the script I use is the same
benchmark I use for the numbers I got
before and this is Brennan reports mode
which means that it's gonna give you
lots of detail about the death of your
through slow trees are training how long
it took if you see if you look at the
bottom you see that 12 cores are being
used like 100 cents so this is cool look
like this wasn't possible because we can
compile a site down with overtime P and
this is it's fast it's great I don't
know when we want to watch this
but it's works mmm let's not talk so um
all the slides are on this get home I'm
Thomas JB fan on Twitter if you caught
me about things and thank you for coming
[Applause]
Thank You Thomas any questions is there
a reason why they offer certain
advantages over other methods of
reference we want to include more the
model inspection field is developing as
a research topic and these parts of
dependence and permutation points has
been around longer and so we includes
them which should be included and we
solve happened to include permutation
points for this release I think so we
want to include more because it turns
out inspecting your models and see how
they and see how they behave is
important to us so these techniques
it's the beginning like me personally I
do wants more inspection tools so that
you could inspect your models and get
more insight about what's going on
can we say now that we it's getting
there
um so for certain benchmarks it's the
same speed as IBM what we wants also
4422 it sports missing values okay sorry
you could put in the missing values and
it works as well so it's that's very
cool what's what we want more from it is
native categorical support because you
could train trees much faster if there's
a native way to do categories that's in
general for any tree and we want to
support sparse yes you guys one hand
code sometimes even one hand coding and
running through tree you need a very
deep tree to recreate what will happen
if you just natively have category
categories and your algorithm so there's
there's ways to like it's very good now
for this it's very good now and we they
will improve as as time goes on for the
next release we're working on this these
ideas old ones are so they're no they're
the both exists concurrently they're
happy to that kind of happy together
I recommend you using this because it's
it's it's been very good because it's
it's written to take advantage of multi
processing yeah you could use and jobs
intercept in this case you have to set
the environmental variable it's very
easy available
we can't I haven't thought about that I
don't know we're gonna kind of power
against Korra but for here foresight on
it was very easy to get it to work with
open em open MP open
P like GPM also uses openmp and xep
saltier than P so it's kind of standard
so this is R and we ran it's the yeah it
was the best tool for the job their
plans for the entire SK learn library or
just so it's four we do have two other
plotting functions that also has the API
it's called plot plot precision recall
and plot RCA you see so we have the we
have it and we want to expand this API
for all the planning authorities so
every plank you totally from here on
we'll have will return the disk object
storing the competition so that you
could change the style after the fact
and not recalculate like this is the
goal like we will have a lot more and 0
no next release
[Applause]